remakes and reboots are all the rage
these days in fact they're so popular
that even films from this century
are already getting the refresh
treatment from fantasy films to slasher
flicks these are the remakes of 21st
century films we can expect to see in
the near future with a star-studded cast
including James McAvoy and Tilda Swinton
2005 s The Chronicles of Narnia The Lion
the Witch and the Wardrobe made 745
million dollars worldwide and was one of
the most popular films released that
year it even went on to win a
well-deserved Academy Award for Best
makeup and hairstyling the next
installment was Prince Caspian in 2008
followed by the voyage of the Dawn
Treader in 2010 the film's continued to
be popular but not enough to warrant
another film and the series fourth entry
the Silver Chair was scrapped altogether
however now that game of Thrones is over
there's a great big fantasy shaped whole
for Hollywood to fill so Netflix is
preparing to reboot the Narnia series in
both TV and movie form with 7 books to
adapt and both feature films and series
in the works the streaming service is
about to become a truly magical place it
has holy stuff with its iffy script and
hokey special effects 2011's Green
Lantern was a disaster of heroic
proportions in fact the only positive
anyone can seem to find about Green
Lantern is the film introduced Ryan
Reynolds and Blake Lively who fell in
love on the set and are now married with
three children
DC is bringing the lantern back already
the films working title is Green Lantern
Corps and the screenplay is being
written by DC chief creative officer
Geoff Johns who also wrote Aquaman and
Wonder Woman 1984 Jones is well aware of
the various missteps from the first film
and he's working to make sure those
aren't repeated in his new screenplay
with all their success turning Animated
Classics into live-action films it
should come as no surprise that Disney
has a lilo and Stitch project in the
works lilo and Stitch follows a
rambunctious little Hawaiian girl named
lilo and her caretakers sister Nani
after the death of their parents in a
tragic car accident to help lilo deal
with her grief Nani
her a pet named stitch who turns out to
actually be an alien science project
that escaped to earth filled with
ukulele tunes and lush Hawaiian imagery
lilo and stitch is ultimately a story
about Ohana
ohana means family family means nobody
gets left behind
soon we'll be welcoming a new lilo and
stitch into the Disney family the remake
is being penned by Mike Van ways and
live-action
Aladdin producers Dan Lin and Jonathan
eirick will be overseeing production no
casting information is available yet but
hopefully the cast will reflect Lee
Lowe's home of kawaii and feature lots
of Native Hawaiian representation the
hit Pirates of the Caribbean franchise
may have worn out its welcome by the
fifth film but that hasn't stopped
Disney from pushing ahead with a remake
with a fresh new cast deadpool writers
Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick had been on
deck to write a screenplay that would
bring an edgier twist to the franchise
however both writers jumped ship in
February 2009 teen leaving the project
without a captain or rudder for a while
the future of the project seemed
uncertain but in late 2019 Disney
brought on Chernobyl creator Craig Mazin
and former pirate scribe Ted Elliott to
craft the screenplay leaving the future
of the franchise looking bright for a
moment there it looked like the Resident
Evil franchise was coming to an end with
the final chapter in 2016 but two years
later a new reboot was already in the
works the news broke during Cannes Film
Festival 2018 when it was announced that
47 meters down director johannes roberts
would write and direct the new film
screenwriter greg russo has already
written a screenplay but we're not sure
if roberts is revising Bruce's version
or starting from scratch as for Resident
Evil star Emilio Vova CH she's been
vocal about her displeasure with the
news voicing suspicions that the
producers are doing this just for money
and not for love of the game or the fans
sounds like there may be some bad zombie
blood behind the scenes Shrek was a
global phenomenon that spawned several
equally loved sequels and television
specials as well as multiple spin-offs
it may seem almost sacrilegious to
reboot the 2001 film but upcoming writer
and director Chris melody andriy has
said when you look back on those vocal
performances from the original they're
awesome and while you certainly could
make a case for a complete reinvention
I find myself responding to my own
nostalgic feelings of wanting to go back
to those characterizations melody andriy
has said he'd be interested in bringing
back the original cast which makes the
next Shrek film sound like more sequel
than reboot
however he has also said that it's been
challenging finding a story that doesn't
feel like just another sequel and that
the story he's working on is entirely
new leaving us unsure of exactly what
form the new Shrek will take DreamWorks
2011 animated comedy Puss in Boots
followed Puss and his pre shrek
adventures and was so successful that it
was subsequently adapted into the
television show The Adventures of Puss
in Boots produced by Netflix but if you
still can't get enough of Katt swinging
swords then prepare for another
adventure since a reboot is coming soon
Despicable Me creator and illumination
entertainment founder Chris Smelley Don
dree told variety he's working on an
entirely new story for the swashbuckling
feline we don't have any details on the
plot yet but melody Andriy says he
wouldn't be averse to having the old
cast returned for the remake
eunsung hos heart-stopping south korean
zombie film train to Busan was an
instant classic and a tall order to
remake but if anyone's up to the
challenge its James Wan the harrowing
story follows a father and his young
daughter who find themselves trapped on
a train at the beginning of a zombie
apocalypse between the tender story that
unfolds between the father and daughter
and endearing performances from the
supporting cast trained to busan's
ability to balance its high-concept
premise with the humanity of its
characters helped it achieve both
critical and financial success after an
extensive bidding war new line will be
the studio behind James wons
english-language remake written by his
longtime Annabel collaborator Gary
Doberman while there's no casting or
other news available yet about the
remake the upcoming sequel to the
original film train to Busan - peninsula
can help pass the time check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]